now a new report out today says that
many people will be up to sixteen
hundred pounds worse off this year
because of rising energy costs and
rocketing inflation so can the tory
leadership candidates offer any help
well joining me now is former defense
secretary and liz trust supporter penny
mordant a very good morning to you penny
morton thanks so much for talking to us
here today
first of all when you were standing for
number 10 you said that your plans for
the economy were based on
sound money
tackling inflation to help with the cost
of living and targeted tax cuts
can you genuinely say that liz truss's
plans tick any or all of those boxes
yes so i was the candidate sort of the
halfway house between rishi and liz's
policy platforms and the reason why i
have chosen to support liz in this
contest
i could have remained
undeclared but i i think this is too
important the reason why i've gone with
her
is because i think she does understand
that our nation is at a an inflection
point and all of the opportunities that
we want to see come to us investment and
other opportunities aren't going to land
on our lap we've got to work for them
we've got to be able to compete we've
got to get more productive we've got to
get supply-side reforms to happen
and that is something that liz does
understand so that is why i've gone with
her her tax cuts are funded she has a
plan uh she has a plan to get growth
back into our economy and that is what
we need to do
well yes but going by your
prime principles that you laid out you
talked about the tax cuts for example
but tax cuts paid through borrowing have
the risk of being inflationary this is
something that the former deputy
governor of the bank of england told me
yesterday he said there's a real risk
that will prompt inflation you said
tackling inflation was one of your
priorities
on the issue of sound money liz trust
has announced tens of billions of pounds
of tax cuts paid through
headroom which may no longer be there
because of the rising rates of inflation
and when it comes to targeted tax cuts
which is another thing you said you
wanted at the moment the reversal of the
rise in national insurance benefits
people on higher salaries so much more
on those on lower salaries so i'm just
wondering do you really feel that she's
living up to the the ideals that you set
out when you were running for leadership
yes of course i've had conversations
with both rishi and liz since i was
eliminated from the contest uh tax cuts
don't have to be inflationary because
we're dealing with the twin problems of
inflation but also weak demand
in the economy her tax cutting program
is funded
it is going to matter very much the
sequence and timing of when things are
done i think she's been right to
put forward a
an emergency budget
clearly there's support for that from
other quarters in the papers today
both in terms of addressing the cost of
living issues but also to really get
growth back into the economy it's all
very well alleviating a problem and the
the squeeze that people are feeling
but we've got to get growth back into
the economy if we don't want that to
become the norm well let's talk about
the the squeeze that people are facing
liz trust has made it clear that she
wants to handle it through tax cuts
rather than handouts as she puts it but
today's poverty report is showing that
four in every five of the country's lone
parents pensioners and large families
are going to be in fuel poverty after
the rises in inflation so is this trust
genuinely saying that
she won't be expanding direct payments
to support them because she doesn't want
to go against conservative orthodoxy no
she's not she's not ruled out all future
help in fact part of her the reason for
her putting an emergency budget forward
is to really address some of these
issues but what she has i think rightly
challenged is the wisdom of taking large
sums of money out of people's pockets in
tax and then giving some of it back in
ever more complicated ways she's making
a general point about the merits of
enabling people to keep more of what
they earn and i think that is the right
principle well no she said she didn't
want to do to help people via handouts
but you're saying that she will consider
handouts she's not she's not ruled out
further help she's already put forward
uh some uh help for people this autumn
clearly the government has already done
a lot i was speaking to nadim zahaway
yesterday
about some of the things that he's
looking at so that whoever is coming in
has got some some further options to
look at there's a huge amount of of
focus on this and of course nadeem has
also announced for
liz truss so it's not she's ruling out
uh
all future help
that's a misinterpretation of what she
said
what she is looking at though is
enabling people to keep more of the
money that they earn it makes no sense
to take money off of people and then to
give it back in very very complicated
ways we need to simplify this and we
need to ensure that households are
resilient as possible and stopping
taking large sums of tax off people is
one way of doing that okay well let's
look at the the tax reversal of national
insurance for example how does that help
the vulnerable people those people that
this report said are going to be so
badly hit
come
later in the year people on benefits
pensioners those not earning enough to
be paying national insurance anyway so
look we can help people in a whole
variety of ways you mentioned pensioners
the older you are generally speaking the
higher your cost of living
liz is committed to the the triple lock
uh there are all sorts of things that we
are already doing in terms of uh
measures that will be brought in this
autumn but what liz also recognizes is
as well as
taking those immediate pressures off of
people you also have to deal with this
issue uh more long term and that means
getting growth back into our economy it
means not taxing jobs it means actually
stimulating the economy pushing through
a program of work that she's outlined on
supply side to really enable us to be
competitive and also addressing those
issues uh so that we're not one of the
most uncompetitive nations with regard
to tax
next april those are the things we also
have to do in tandem with helping people
day-to-day
and clearly it's important to look
further ahead but there's a very
immediate problem right now and you
mentioned pensioners a typical fuel bill
will take up a third of the statutory
pension
so
whatever you think about people people
struggling older people struggling on a
political level does it make sense then
to not tackle
not tackle this i mean it's politically
not a very clever move a lot of
conservatives are pensioners
so look there's there's things that liz
has already announced with regard to the
the green levees she wants to have a
moratorium on that uh she's looking at
other ways that uh she can uh assist
people in that but we also have to
address the underlying problems in the
economy and
just waiting for for that to to resolve
itself is not an option we actually have
to start working to ensure that we can
compete that we can
create high-wage jobs that we can do all
of those things that is actually going
to put us in a much better and much more
resilient position the the economy is
very volatile at the moment it's quite
right that we have a reset moment when a
new prime minister comes in liz has said
that she will do that and i'm interested
in supporting a candidate that
recognizes the situation we're in at the
moment but also is still ambitious about
delivering that brexit dividend liz can
do both and i've seen her in action we
came into parliament at the same time in
2010 she's someone that is pragmatic
she's evidence-led but she's absolutely
driven and determined to deliver for
this country and that's why she's got my
backing
and we've heard from the former prime
minister gordon brown today saying that
that such is the crisis that
not only liz trust rishi sunak but the
prime minister boris johnson should all
come together right now
and come up with an emergency budget he
can't wait until
a leadership
winner is is crowned if you like would
liz trust do that
so look i understand that the focus is
on the the leadership contest but there
is still a huge amount of work going on
in government as i say i spoke to the
chancellor just yesterday about some
things that he is doing
this this work continues and of course
parliament isn't sitting at the moment
but when that person comes in whether it
is rishi or liz there will be
some more options for them to to look at
they'll be able to look at the the
fiscal position uh which we're currently
looking at a red book that's very out of
date and they'll be able to take
decisions quickly on that liz has said
that she will do that she is going to
have an emergency budget that will both
address the cost of living issues and
the things we need to get our public
services really recovering from the the
pandemic but also she has her eyes on
the prize of getting real growth back
into our economy
a quick reflection on your time in the
leadership contest it got pretty toxic
at points didn't it um there were quite
a few people that seemed to be
on a concerted effort to
stop you progressing i know lord frost
an ally of liz trust was pretty scathing
to you over the brexit talks i mean he
was quite brutal he talked about you not
being a master of the dieter dale not
fully accountable not always visible how
did that feel at the time well look i
have a
different reflection on my events in in
government working with lord frost and
others but look this isn't about me it's
not about my feelings
it's about making sure that in a few
weeks time we can have a team that can
come together and deliver for this
country we have got to get people
getting access to the healthcare that
they need huge challenges obviously to
overcome uh to do that we've got to
ensure that we can give the reassurance
that people need now with regard to
their household budgets and we've got to
also enable business to really thrive to
make the investments that we want them
to make those are the things that we
need to be focused on it doesn't matter
about my ego my feelings i'm going to
work with the new prime minister to
deliver on those things and i hope that
is going to be liz truss okay well penny
morton we appreciate your time this
morning thanks for coming on and talking
to us thank you